[Music]
selena quintanilla is still the queen of
Tejano music thanks to hit songs like
this
[Music]
et mas is celebrating the 25th
anniversary of Selena's iconic album
amor prohibido you have a dream don't
let anybody take it away and you always
believe that the impossible is always
possible Selena's infectious charisma
and unstoppable talent left a permanent
mark on the world that no doubt impacted
the women in music we know today God
sent me that role for a reason so I
could learn from her so I could always
have her as an inspiration Selena is the
biggest role model in my life
this whole album just embodied you know
her artistry oh my god it's Selena the
song I'm with RiRi though is such a big
selena record has that like Romeo and
Juliet kind of story and it doesn't
matter where we come from or what we
look like or what our families think of
a society tells us we're gonna be
together because that's what real love
is you can listen to it now ten years
from now 50 years from now and it just
still sounds so fresh and new and you
can hear her beautiful one-of-a-kind
voice and her spirit it shines through
the records
[Music]
my mum she's just something or someone
that I've just I've always looked up to
and being from Texas growing out the
knee off free whirls and everything like
that it was hard not to know her and
love her es como su en el corazon cuando
hay muchas token oliver este hombre
pasar sepal patel core so nice when I
come over DVD Bom Bom
[Music]
she was such an icon and she was so
talented in a wrong way she had a lot of
trust in herself and that's what we need
in this industry to keep on going for
other people to believe in you then you
have to believe in you I think she was
an amazing woman
I knew everything about her and I really
identify with her I'm a fan of
everything that she did sell enough
women primeira liga de la mujer
cameron's pero para para starred on the
story
es una Estrella que nunca ha um Brad
Narita are you stopped para siempre it's
just a really really really cool to see
also a mexican-american women be able to
do something in a in an area of felted
man you know like be the door opener for
many young girls like me to be able to
perform in in these great spaces that's
one of my favorite records that could
play and instantly bring me to tears
[Music]
the passion and her voice the pain that
she exudes through her emotions is just
it really touches your soul
[Music]
so I'm going to try not to cry but if I
had the opportunity to speak with Selina
herself I would like to say thank you
for giving me such a great example of
what it is to be your true authentic
self I would tell her thank you thank
you for being the woman that you were
and that I love you and I will always
love you I would have so many questions
how hard it is in an industry and what
her experience was like starting a new
genre especially taking over a genre
that you know there wasn't a lot of
women going into the final music and
because we have so much love for family
a passion for family I think I was like
ask questions about that tooth just it
was a great lesson to know that you know
you're not promised tomorrow and you
have to you have to love and live for
today
[Music]